have you fallen in love with the magical
sound of the classical guitar
i've spoken to so many guitarists who
tell me that they would love to play the
classical guitar but they're intimidated
by learning to read standard notation or
they don't know what to do with their
nails or perhaps they're struggling to
learn these new techniques if that
sounds like you you'll be happy to know
that i've just finished my online
classical guitar course this is an
introductory course designed to welcome
you to the wonderful world of the
classical attar in it i'm going to teach
you everything you need to know so that
you can start playing the enchanting
music that you know and love as a
teenager i was an electric guitar player
playing a lot of rock and metal in
different bands and i remember when i
first heard classical guitar i was
stunned i was completely captivated by
the sounds i was hearing i couldn't
believe that it was coming out of a
guitar
[Music]
and after hearing it i really felt
compelled to learn how to play it i
frankly wish i would have had this
course back then since then i've
completed two degrees in classical
guitar released several cds been a part
of international tours and have taught
countless students so i've decided to
take all that teaching experience and
distill it into this in-depth classical
guitar course over 12 large lessons
classical guitar pro guides you in a fun
way to learn everything you need to know
you're going to learn how to hold the
guitar tune the guitar
we cover music theory and how to read
standard notation
how to practice
caring for your nails and playing
without nails
right hand technique
left hand technique you'll also get much
more including quizzes
downloadable pdfs
and mp3 backing tracks to help you
practice
at the end of the course i'm excited to
announce that there will be a simulated
recital in which i take you to a
beautiful recital hall and then i'm
going to tell you a little bit about how
to perform and then we'll walk on stage
and you'll play along with me as if it's
you playing in this beautiful recital
hall you're going to learn exciting
pieces like malaguena
[Music]
green sleeves
[Music]
famous etudes
[Music]
i've also created some duet versions of
famous classical guitar pieces so that
even as a beginner you can get a taste
of what it's like to play some of the
most famous pieces in the classical
guitar repertoire
[Laughter]
[Music]
so if you've fallen in love with the
elegant sounds of the classical atar and
are ready to start playing on your own
sign up today and get lifetime access to
my new online course classical guitar
pro
[Music]
you